and I I came across a tick tock of a
woman
um saying to always assume the worst in
all men let's pull the clip one of the
reasons why I've had such an amazing
life is because my mom raised me when
she was a bitter divorced woman I'm not
even exaggerating him she talks so much
crap
about men like like without even saying
like under her breath remarks so she'd
be like yeah if they ever pay for it you
know we're like don't count on them you
know it wasn't even like a lot of the
some of my favorite content creators on
here are divorced women those women are
going to tell you the truth more than
anyone and that's why like if I had any
advice to give
younger women especially in their 20s
you know teen like late teens 20s even
into like your early 30s depending on
you know what your goals are and what
you want in life or whatever but even
still don't believe me assume the worst
in all of them until proven otherwise